rebels didn't have to go far to find
their next men's basketball coach
sports director chris matthews here with
more on the hiring of rebel assistant
and former player kevin krueger chris
that's right denise just across the hall
for this one right here there are a lot
of people in this valley who remember
kevin krueger
when he played for his father here now
after years of learning preparing as an
assistant coach
kevin krueger now gets to call the shots
there's something about kevin krueger
that gives you the feeling that he will
succeed he's been around basketball his
entire life and he's learned from one of
the best
you know when you talk about him i think
anybody that's gotten to know him is you
you can sense pretty quickly his
competitiveness kevin is his own person
now gets to call all the shots at unlv
where he once played took the rebels
into the sweet 16. in fact on the plane
ride to chicago
kevin took over the mic here we have the
coach the head coach
some people say he looks like me you put
any pressure on coach about him being
here three years now and this being the
first tournament
experience it's about time we went to
the tournament don't you think
he's got all the traits to be successful
confidence knowledge drive determination
and he's a pretty funny guy something
you may not see at first glance
what are you watching uh enemy at the
gates
again yeah again all right you watched
that last trip didn't you i think some
people don't think he's got
the greatest or most forthcoming
outgoing personality but they're
definitely wrong
kevin just plays everything close to the
best unless it comes to promoting the
program then he's going to shout this
from the rooftops
we're going to work our tails off to get
people back into the thomas and mack and
and
play a style of basketball that that the
city will be proud of
unlv has work to do to get back to days
like this but in college basketball
it doesn't have to take long to bring
back this kind of excitement
finding the right blend and the right
mix is far more important
than signing one guy or two guys that
just grabbed the most attention
all right there's some celebrations
right there now kruger's next big task
is hiring assistant coaches
spoke with him today about that today
we'll see what happens just to convince
some of those guys perhaps the players
to stay with the program
as well denise